♪
>>> SIX YEARS BEFORE GEORGE
FLOYD SAID I CAN'T BREATHE, ERIC
GARNER SPOKE THOSE VERY SAME
WORDS IN A CASE THAT SEEMED TO
HAVE A LOT IN COMMON, BOTH
INVOLVED IN ATTEMPTED ARREST FOR
A NONVIOLENT OFFENSE, BOTH
INVOLVED FORCE, AND BOTH WERE
RULED A HOMICIDE BY THE LOCAL
MEDICAL EXAMINER.
BUT THE OFFICER IN THE GARNER
CASE WAS NEVER CHARGED WITH A
CRIME, WHILE DEREK CHAUVIN IS
GUILTY OF THREE AND THE QUESTION
IS WHY.
WE SPOKE WITH ERIC GARNER'S
MOTHER, GWEN CARR, ABOUT WHAT'S
CHANGED IN AMERICA ABOUT POLICE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WHAT HAS NOT.
>> DO YOU REMEMBER WHERE YOU
WERE TODAY WHEN YOU HEARD THE
NEWS GUILTY ON ALL COUNTS?
>> IN MY HOUSE WITH TWO TVs ON.
>> HOW DID YOU FEEL IN THAT
MOMENT?
>> JUST TEARS STARTED FALLING
FROM MY EYES.
AND I JUST -- I WAS IN THE HOUSE
BY MYSELF.
I WAS ACTING CRAZY.
>> DID YOU FEEL LIKE YOUR SON
WAS THERE IN SOME WAY?
>> YES, I DO.
I KNOW HIS PRESENCE WAS THERE.
AND HE WAS PROBABLY JUMPING WITH
ME.
>> DO YOU REMEMBER HOW YOU FELT
WHEN YOU FIRST HEARD ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO GEORGE FLOYD?
>> I SAID, THIS IS LIKE THE ECHO
FROM THE GRAVE.
>> SO MANY SIMILARITIES AND THEN
ONE VERY BIG DIFFERENCE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
ONE BIG DIFFERENCE, THEY DID GET
JUSTICE.
>> Reporter: IN JULY 2014 AS
BYSTANDERS CAUGHT IT ALL ON
CAMERA, CARR'S SON WAS ACCUSED
OF SELLING LOOSE CIGARETTES AND
PULLED TO THE GROUND BY A POLICE
OFFICER.
ALTHOUGH THAT OFFICER WHO
WRAPPED HIS ARMS AROUND ERIC
GARNER'S NECK WAS LATER FIRED,
HE WAS NEVER CHARGED WITH A
CRIME.
>> I CAN'T BREATHE!
>> Reporter: GARNER'S LAST WORDS
HELPED IGNITE A MOVEMENT.
>> I CAN'T BREATHE!
>> THE FIRST TIME MOST PEOPLE
HEARD THE PHRASE I CAN'T BREATHE
IN A MARCH WAS AFTER YOUR SON'S
DEATH.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> DO YOU THINK THE OUTRAGE AND
THE DEMONSTRATIONS FOLLOWING THE
DEATH OF YOUR SON HELPED CREATE
THE ATMOSPHERE NECESSARY FOR
JUSTICE TODAY?
>> IT SET THE STAGE.
I'M PRETTY SURE MY SON'S DEATH
AND THE OUTRAGE THAT THE PEOPLE
SHOWED AT THAT TIME SET THE
STAGE SO WHEN OTHER INJUSTICES
HAPPEN, THIS IS WHY I THINK
EVERYBODY CAME OUT.
WOW, THIS IS HAPPENING AGAIN.
>> DID YOU EXPECT AT THE TIME
WHEN YOU HEARD THE DETAILS OF
THE FLOYD CASE THAT THAT FAMILY
WOULD GET AN INDICTMENT, A TRIAL
AND NOW A CONVICTION?
>> NO, I REALLY DIDN'T THINK SO
BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT HAD HAPPENED
ON PREVIOUS OCCASIONS WITH A LOT
OF THE FAMILIES.
>> Reporter: EVEN AS SHE
CELEBRATED THE VERDICT IN THE
FLOYD CASE, SHE SAYS IT WAS ALSO
COMPLICATED, A FEELING OF
ILLATION FOR THE FLOYD FAMILY
BUT ALSO REFLECTION ON WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO OTHERS.
>> I'M NOT ONLY ANGRY, I'M
OUTRAGED THAT THIS CAN KEEP ON
HAPPENING.
IT HAPPENED WITH ME.
IT HAPPENED WITH OTHERS THAT WE
NEVER WILL KNOW ABOUT.
IT HAPPENED WITH GEORGE FLOYD.
WHEN WILL IT END?
IS THIS THE END OF IT?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> DOES TODAY FEEL IN SOME SMALL
WAY LIKE JUSTICE FOR ERIC GARNER
AS WELL.
>> IT'S A PIECE OF JUSTICE FOR
US ALL.
>> THERE'S NO BRINGING HIM BACK.
>> NEVER.
>> BUT IS IT SOME SMALL SOLACE
KNOWING THAT WHAT HAPPENED TO
HIM HELPED SET IN MOTION WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY?
>> YES.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THE BITTER WITH
THE SWEET.
YOU HAVE TO SAY, MY -- I SAY, MY
SON DIDN'T DIE IN VAIN.
HE SET THE PRECEDENCE FOR THIS
DAY TO HAPPEN.
>> SHE'S AN AMAZING WOMAN.
>> SURE IS.
>> AND THERE'S THAT SMALL
SOLACE, BUT SHE CLARIFIES AND
REALLY MAKES THE POINT STRONGLY
THAT THIS IS A MILESTONE MOMENT,
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN EVERYBODY
WHO IS PART OF THE MOVEMENT GOES
HOME AND SITS ON THE COUCH.
>> IN 2019 THERE WAS A
DOCUMENTARY CALLED "AMERICAN
TRIAL," IT WAS A MOCK TRIAL OF
WHAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED IF
THERE HAD BEEN A TRIAL.
THE FAMILY PARTICIPATED IN IT.
IT HAD AN INCREDIBLE ARRAY OF
PEOPLE TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, ERIC GARNER'S
MOTHER LED THE WAY ON THAT.
AND THAT WAS HER FORM OF
JUSTICE, BEING ABLE TO SEE AN
OUTCOME OF SOME WAY.
>> I WAS STRUCK BY WHEN YOU --
WHEN SHE SAID, IS THIS THE END
OF IT?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> OH, NO.
AND THE SIMILARITIES IN HER
SON'S CASE ARE SO STRONG AND
THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER CASES
WHERE THERE WERE NO CHARGES OR
THE OFFICER WAS LET OFF.
IT'S A REMINDER THAT OUTCOMES IN
THESE CASES -- MINNESOTA IS THE
EXCEPTION.
MOST OFFICERS DO NOT FACE
CHARGES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> MOST ARE NOT CONVICTED.
AND THE REASON IS BECAUSE THE
LAWS VARY DRAMATICALLY PLACE TO
PLACE.
AND SO THE OUTCOMES DO AS WELL.
THERE MAY BE EQUALITY UNDER THE
LAW, BUT